ya comienza el entrenamiento de la
selección argentina aquí en doja el
primero a la primera sesión pensando en
esa gran final contra los franceses y
con ese sueño de levantar su tercera
copa mundo los argentinos que vienen de
una sesión de descanso después de
haberse impuesto sobre los croatas la
selección dirigida por Lionel escaloni
que aprovecha ese día más de preparación
que tienen respecto a sus rivales para
esa final tras haber jugado su semifinal
un día antes que el combinado galo el
combinado de Direct de precisamente que
realicé hoy una jornada de recuperación
después de esa Victoria contra los
marroquíes en semifinales por 2 a 0 se
habla mucho en la selección francesa de
esos reportes de la prensa europea que
señala que Karim Benzema del Balón de
Oro regresaría para disputar esa final
contra los argentinos al respecto se le
preguntó por supuesto al seleccionador
después de ese triunfo contra el equipo
africano dijo de sham que no quería ni
siquiera responder a esa pregunta
Respecto a los otros equipos Croacia
Marruecos que tuvo una sesión de
descanso en esta jornada y Croacia que
sí realizó entrenamiento Croacia y
Marruecos que disputan el sábado ese
partido por el tercer puesto volviendo a
la final se espera que para este partido
vuelva el presidente Emmanuel macron
nazar en la grada el mandatario que
defendió su visita aquí en Qatar en
medio de las acusaciones y críticas por
parte de la oposición en Francia se
desconoce si su homólogo Alberto
Fernández realizará lo mismo desde la
presidencia del país sudamericano No
aclararon si finalmente Fernández
viajaría aquí a Qatar en medio de una
política de austeridad Respecto a los
viajes por la que pasa el gobierno
sudamericano